there are millions of people in the
world using sign language and a big part
of them are in China and right now we
know that if we acknowledge especially
the people grow up we're fast so from my
view I think it's a right time to do
well some technology happened this
project is a sign language translator it
translates from one sign language to
another it helps the hearing and the
Deaf communicate easy one she art oddity
Achieva you can communicate between
American Sign Language and tiny sign
language or potentially any sign
languages to any other natural language
the Kinect will capture the sign
language and then recognize the meaning
of the sign language included in the
posture the trajectory and then there's
an automatic translation into spoken
language
what lets you buy sugar I really like
this the basic modes are translator mode
and a communication mode the translator
mode is showing how single words can be
translated from a sign into a written
form or how to translate a written form
into a sign in communication mode we can
actually use a translation of full
sentences the avatar is used in the
system to represent the hearing person
doing signing it's a proxy for the
hearing
it helps me to connect with others since
I'm the graphics guy so my main response
is helps them to develop a very
efficient and good culinary avatar so
lakhs of people can use this al-adha to
generate some Sun language spear to
communicate with other people with the
sacred situation from one posture to
another and combining also the
trajectory so we're using machine many
technology and cutting kinesiology to
make the final decision of what's the
means of the just show me how
imagine a deaf person walking into a
doctor's office the doctor is a regular
doctor probably can't speak in sign
language hello my name is dr. Wong what
is hurting you but the patient wants to
communicate with the doctor today they'd
have to use their maybe writing and it
would be very artificial but here with
this technology they could use signing
and the doctor would be able to
understand that that signing so another
scenario is a information kiosk so at
airport hello how can I help you and
rather than say the person seeking
information at that kiosk me in death
imagine if the person that the
information kiosk was was dead which way
is the taxi stand now a hearing person
could come to that kiosk and to ask
questions of their death person and the
system could help them communicate with
the deaf person in voice
please go outside the terminal and make
a left
great thank you if I can take a keyword
for this project that will be
cooperation because this project
wouldn't be possible without experts in
the sign language experts integration of
the whole system and also from Microsoft
research side some key technologies the
main benefit to collaborate with maps of
research Asia is they could give us more
support on connect technology itself
because connect from Maxim and also they
have some expert in machine translation
and this is also a kind of language
translation from sign language to spoken
language so I think the greasing about
these collaborations people coming from
totally different disciplines and from
the different organizations here so I
really you're not from it so one of the
things that we're doing with this
project is working with the deaf
community directly we're working with a
school in China for the death and
they've helped us understand better that
there's quite an isolated feeling in the
in debt even today what overwhelmingly
you feel when you see it working is a
certain magic but you know that there's
more work to do
but you can see the potential there that
one day this is going to be something
that it's going to transform lives
you